sasson screed victory has been leaked by
Kotaku in the past hour or so not really
sure how this happened they seem to have
been given a demo by Ubisoft but yeah
are also following up with Ubisoft yeah
so therefore we've I think on context as
well see if we can if they're gonna like
talked about this stuff nobody knows
when this was going to be announced
maybe at the vgas this weekend that
seems like a solid bet could have been
yeah so the planet is a straight up
trailer for this kotaku ha don't have
the trailer but they've got a bunch of
screenshots yeah they described it as
like a not actual as like a gameplay
target video of like this is what it
should be like right now so they sort of
produced that as like this is what we're
aiming for and right here you're seeing
one a screenshot of one of the new
gadgets they showed off the grappling
hook yeah so this apparently is in
Charing Cross station which would be a
you know relatively big or well known
area and a big interior space you have a
place to put that grappling hook that
they said the vehicle combat stuff as
well was was sort of new gameplay
additions they were bringing to it but
it's kind of hard to judge where this
like there seems to be those two
Assassin's Creed games those one the
breakthrough and everyone loves and then
sort of middling ones and I'm not really
sure what we got this year like Peter
you're pretty frustrated with just the
sheer amount of them that are that are
coming out at the moment I mean we live
in a cycle of like marketing in this
industry an assassin's creed is one of
those titles that is marketed so heavily
all year round because there's always a
game on the horizon they're always
announcing a new one it's always there
I'm just tired of seeing these games
like people I know who loved the series
are tired of playing it like I'm not
really sure who really wants more of
these obviously there are people buying
them but the whole like they're like the
cloud of noise around me is basically
saying boo why and I share that
sentiment like I I can't get excited for
it unity had its fair share of launch
issues as well and you know we can be
pretty picky when it comes to bugs and
games at launch but unity it seemed was
definitely perhaps something that was
pushed out just a little bit too early
yeah and I feel like that's one of the
things that really contributes this kind
of fatigue that people get like the
Peter describes is when the game comes
out and when it's not even you know a
hundred percent or you know no games
gonna be a hundred sent bug free but
like reasonably bug-free like that you
know the majority many many years
reporting those issues when that comes
out when it's like you could have used a
few more months on this it just kind of
exists it's just sort of sheds light on
the damaging sort of aspects of this
crazy fast cycle it's worth noting that
Assassin's Creed victory is the first
game that the the lead is studio like
the sort of course mainline Assassin's
Creed game that the lead is yet they're
Quebec's to do not their Montreal studio
I'm not sure if that's gonna you know
have any sort of notable effect in terms
of have they had more time to work in so
it'll be more polished or are there
gonna be you know the grappling hook and
the vehicle combat is I can somehow make
running through the city feel different
you know even though it's one was a
Victorian are like 1800s so like this is
within a hundred years of the unity that
just came out really the timing of this
coming out i think is like not optimal
like your games have been out for less
than a month yeah the story like should
be about them ship and you know i don't
know what's the motivation is it hey
guys we got another one coming so if you
didn't if you got problems with that one
there's not one on the horizon or let's
change the narrative so people are
excited about and it gets you thinking
about all these things that aren't the
game and when a game is announced you
should be thinking about the game and
what's interesting about it not about
the marketing cycle and not about you
know the development cycle necessarily
but when the circumstances conspire to
to be like this it's you can't help but
think it's a big way like ugly you know
who knows maybe they were going to
release this in 2015 there's this
information and the trailer and whatnot
and the Quebec stuff is interesting
because thats 2d has been around for a
long time but they mostly concentrated
on sort of support for games like watch
dogs and are they were helping with ac3
they've done a lot of mobile stuff as
well so maybe this is like you never
know when a studio finally gets its
chance at something you know releasing
one of the sort of Triple A games on
their own maybe that's when they like
pick up the mantle and say alright we're
gonna make this our own and do something
interesting with it I'm kind of
interested in a Victorian era London one
but then I'm probably one of those
people who love that series but I'm
definitely getting like overcome and if
people are tired and if this is the
studio's chance to finally like take
something and run with it what a crappy
opportunity because people are tired of
that series maybe they're not gonna
latch on to it cuz the average person
doesn't know who's making this game and
that maybe it's going to be this like
fresh take and and and if I'm
it's like Ubisoft announced behind good
and evil to a hell of a long time ago
yeah I would so I would be so excited to
hear about that game something like
brand new and interesting versus another
game that was a sequel at least that's
you know like very far from its original
source material yeah yeah I mean we'll
just just I mean something that's I mean
yes relative to blast us in creating
this relative to the last beyond good
and evil but yeah it's a you're saying
you want a new ubisoft game that's
interesting and a new franchise no not a
new fracture is gonna go an evil whether
there's you should stay watching the
lobby because we're going to back it's
just a couple of minutes with the crew
again the peter is in fact reviewing